anna est blanche
ce sont les prénoms de mes deux grand
mère paternelle et maternelle et depuis
que je suis toute petite je me fais ce
geste là anna blanche et moi depuis que
je suis petit jeu je sais mes parents
toujours voulu le meilleur pour nous mes
frères et moi j'ai deux frères aînés
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vouloir le
meilleur pour ses enfants
j'ai toujours perçu de la souffrance
dans ma famille quand j'avais 4 ans j'ai
fait un rêve j'ai rêvé un cauchemar plus
tôt j'ai rêvé que mes parents mes frères
étaient dans une prison et moi je
visitais cette prison et je les
regardais j'étais impuissante à 12 ans
j'ai trouvé ma vocation psychologue
j'allais être psychologue pour
comprendre et surtout pour dominer pour
sauver ma famille pour dominer mais peur
voilà je vais comprendre et je veux tout
savoir sur la la psyché je fais mes
études de psychologie
j'évite soigneusement finalement la
branche de la psychopathologie vous
voyez l'hôpital psychiatrique
j'avais peur dans ma famille il ya des
gens qui ont connu l'hôpital
psychiatrique je parle de ma famille
voyez la grande famille les cousins les
oncles et tantes il y en eut connu
l'hôpital la dépression l'alcoolisme au
non j'allais prendre une autre
spécialité finalement est toujours dans
la psychologie
quand j'ai 29 ans je vis en couple et je
découvre un matin que je suis enceinte
et à ce moment là tout de suite j'ai une
phrase qui m'arrive comme ça me dit ah
bah maintenant tu es enceinte il va te
quitter je sais que cette phrase nous ça
vient quelques mois plus tard monfils
n'est et un an plus tard son père me
quittes
et là on va s'arrêter quelques instants
sur cet événement pour la plupart des
femmes qui se retrouvent seules avec un
ou plusieurs enfants
c'est une situation très difficile pour
quelques femmes c'est plutôt soulageant
mais pour moi ça a été une catastrophe
quelque chose mais mais c'était mais le
ciel m'est tombé sur la tête vraiment
j'ai pas compris quoi
en plus le même mois j'avais un projet
professionnel qui s'est envolé dans des
circonstances je vais pas les décrire
ici ça je me suis retrouvé du jour au
lendemain j'ai pu rien j'avais plus
d'argent j'ai emprunté de l'argent à ma
famille à la banque et je me disais pas
ok ok alors ce mois ci je peux payer mon
loyer
mais le mois prochain j'en sais rien
qu'est ce que je vais faire
et là je vous assure c'était moi qui
avais voulu tout mettre sous contrôle
voyez là il ya tous les démons qui sont
remontés voyez les petits démons qui me
disait mauvaise mère meira compétentes
professionnels incompétente
tu as tout raté dans ta vie tu aurais tu
rates râteau toujours
et être quoi alors
réflexe de survie familiale je m'en suis
rendu compte après voyez je comment j'ai
survécu à tout ça parce que j'ai quand
même
voilà des insomnies les choses et ben
c'était bonjour isabelle ça va ah ouais
ça va très très bien parfait impeccable
1 isabelle tu as maigri 10 danses assad
va bien et ouais je maigrissais mais
c'est envers de man mais rien ne se
voyaient est un un jour un soir j'ai vu
ma vie sur un fil et je me suis dit ok
si tu t'laisses aller il se passe quoi
ok je me laisse aller sur la droite
et là j'ai vu ma vie j'ai vu hôpital
psychiatrique dépression alcoolisme tout
la totale j'ai dit non
un jeu vidéo bon ça c'est pas possible
ok à gauche c'est quoi à bas à gauche
c'était aux oies
comment je vais faire ces eaux là j'ai
j'ai aucun moyen mais je vais me battre
je sais que je vais me battre ana et
blanche
anna c'est ma grand mère paternelle son
jeune amant l'a laissé quand il a appris
qu'elle était enceinte et elle a élevé
son enfant est né tout seul
les premières années et blanche
elle a élevé seule aussi son enfant est
né parce que son jeune amant l'a quitté
quand il a su qu'elle était enceinte et
elle a épousé après mon grand père et
mon grand père est un enfant de la dass
et là je me suis dit ah oui ça aurait un
lien mes angoisses mes peurs moi j'avais
peur qu'on prenne mon fils à la dass
j'avais peur de devenir pauvres de ne
pas pouvoir les levées c'était une
angoisse abyssal ok je suis dit bon ben
voilà d'accord ok donc je m'appelle
isabelle anna blanche
je suis désespéré je suis complètement
incompétente pour tous je fais quoi
hélas cadeau de la vie
j'ai fait un rêve
un vrai rêve là c'était pas un cauchemar
c'est un vrai rêve en fait c'est trois
rêves une trilogie
le premier rêve en fait je je suis dans
mon petit deux pièces où c'était mon
rêve c'était là où j'habite elle est
soudain je vois une petite porte en haut
je dis tiens cette porte
je n'ai jamais vu j'ouvre la porte et là
je vois une pièce c'est cosy avec une
cheminée un feu qui crépite un fauteuil
une pipe qui fument alors j'ai dit ça
doit être la pièce du propriétaire
quand il sera pas là
j'y vais j'ai un petit lieu pour moi
super personne n'en saura rien quelques
mois plus tard deuxième rêve qui
commence pareil je suis dans mon petit
deux pièces je vois une porte
j'ouvre la porte et là je vois deux
pièces en enfilade si c'est formidable
une grande table je veux dit super jeu
pouvoir recevoir mes amis une terrasse
qui donne sur tout paris je t'aime mais
c'est génial
en fait je paye un loyer pour deux
pièces jaunes et 4 quelques mois plus
tard troisième rêve
pareil je suis dans mon deux pièces
petite porte le louvre est là un palais
un palais jeu j'avance dans ce palais je
vois des lits à baldaquin des tentures
des tapis précieuse je suis émerveillé
et j'ai cette phrase dans mon rêve qui
m'a marqué et je me dis dire que ça fait
trente ans que je vis dans nos deux
pièces alors qu'en fait j'habite un
palais je ne savais même pas et là je
suis dit ok ok comment j'habite mon
palais maintenant ok j'ai cette petite
porte je peux aller dans mon palais
comme enjeu la [ __ ] comme enjeu m'habite
moi même j'avais peur de tout alors
justement je me suis dit isabelle de
quoi tu as peur
qu'est ce qui te fait peur dans la vie
et quand j'avais une peur je me disais
bon allez vas-y et je me suis dit tu vas
tu va transformer le truc tu vas dire
non c'est pas de la peur c'est je met de
l'avant tueur dans ma vie de l' aventure
je je je vais comme en exploration alors
j'ai mis en place plein de choses comme
ça alors voilà par exemple je vous dire
tout ce que j'ai fait mais par exemple
quelque chose qui le terrorisait c'était
le vide alors j'ai j'ai fait un stage
audace ça s'appelait ce stage audace et
alors c'était dans le verdon 200 mètres
de vide alors j'ai tout fait je vais de
la tyrolienne la main courante une
rappel de 200 mètres et la alors j'étais
en train de développer ce que j'écris
maintenant dans dans mes livres c'est à
dire le bon partenaire intérieur vous
voyez le critique
j'essaye de le mettre au placard suis
qu'ils étaient incompétents et le bon
partenaire intérieur qui m'encourageait
alors ce jour là je frappe et c'était
comme ça dans dans le vide enfin vous
voyez le vide il était là en dessous là
et puis j'étais là bon allez je
n'arrivais pas du tout à me décollé de
la corde
le guide il était en haut il devait
surtout regarde en bas vous mais non je
regarde pas en bas j'étais là où
j'arrivais pas du tout aller et je
devais aller isabelle dévoila tu enlèves
ta main oui c'est bien c'est bien oui
bravo
vas-y tu continues oui voilà c'est bien
à ce moment-là ya le guide là tout va
bien isabelle oui je m'en fichais je
sais moi ce qui est important c'est que
j'y arrive et donc voilà donc j'étais
pas à pas pas à pas j'ai apprivoisé mes
peurs et g j'ai commencé à habiter mots
parlés petit à petit
et j'ai re décidé mon travail dans le
sens je les ai choisis déjà je me suis
mise en libéral parce que j'avais une
phrase quand même je disais ok isabelle
quand tu seras sur ton lit de mort
qu'est ce qui te fera dire j'ai réussi
ma vie je suis fier il ya un truc
c'était mettre en libéral hockey hélas
les démons c'était plus à l'intérieur de
moi c'était plutôt à l'extérieur mais ça
va pas te mettre en libéral tout ça
n'est qu'un enfant et 4 crise
bah ouais je les fais est aujourd'hui
bas j'accompagne les gens qui sont à un
moment de leur vie où ils sont en crise
personnelle professionnelle ou à un
moment de leur vie important où ils ont
envie de changer mais voilà ils ont peur
enfin bon voilà tout ce que je viens de
raconter quoi on connaît bien le
processus et je leur dis vous venez d'où
est-ce que vous avez conscience d'où
vous venez de votre famille de ce que
vous avez pris de ce dont vous avez
hérité et qu'est ce que vous voulez
développer
quel permission vous avez envie de vous
donner et je forme aussi des
professionnels des personnes qui veulent
accompagner où elle aussi et pour moi ça
énormément de sens ça a beaucoup de sens
et m'ont pas les intérieurs j'y pense il
est toujours là et je suis toujours en
train d'explorer j'ai pas fini et je
crois que c'est jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
et voyez par exemple j'ai 52 ans je suis
devant vous il ya quelques mois on
m'aurait dit que cette la voyez c'est
c'est encore une pièce que je découvre
parce que pour moi tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter
c'était secret en moi c'était une honte
c'était quelque chose de douloureux
et en fait je me suis dit allez allez
vas-y puis voilà je suis devant vous et
pour ça je voudrais vous remercier
d'être là et puis je vous dire aussi que
on a tous un palais intérieur et et
c'est vous qui avaient la clé du vôtre
merci